parents have listened to ccsd leaders
about the return to school plan tonight
it was the leader's turn to listen to
parents superintendent dr jesus jarrah
held a q a for the ccsd parents facebook
group
so they talked a lot about what the rest
of the year could look like and next
year what that will look like
madison kimbrough joining us now live
with more details madison
yeah tonight's virtual event provided a
platform for parents to ask their
questions
and express their concerns in addition
to talking about what going back to the
classroom will look like
there's one thing everyone can agree on
so the goal is for august to be five
days a week face to face
for all our schools many parents
rejoicing tonight after hearing ccsd
superintendent dr
jara speak out on what the future looks
like for students going back to the
classroom
as of now the plan is to go back to
in-person learning by next fall but the
rest of this school year will be
completed using the hybrid model and as
for kids who are doing better virtually
that will remain an option next year as
well as we see that there's some kids
that
are successful now that they're they
were struggling face to face and now
they're
doing great so we you know and that's a
choice that we're gonna
we're gonna provide for families that's
our goal for parents like julie tandy
she wants her kids to be able to
participate in their after-school
activities
i would like to be able to have more
confidence that we'll be able to
attend some of the sporting activities
and be able to see her
perform to be able to participate in the
activity and
the extracurricular or the sporting
event that they choose
parents who took part say there were
some encouraging things mentioned but
many say
there's still a ways to go but at the
end of the day dr
jarrah says it's all about the kids
these are all his kids these are all
that he cares about every single one of
them
now screen time concerns the use of
hands-on material and sports those were
all major topics of tonight's discussion
dr jarrah did say some encouraging news
that spectators will be allowed
soon to go see their kids students back
playing sports again so hopefully that
will be sometime
in the next month or so reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now
madison thank you for that report the
district deputy superintendent also
answering questions tonight one of which
was about whether some students would
need to stay in school
right through the summer to make up for
what has been such an unpredictable year
so extending the school year through the
summer is a is a possibility
we are we're right now as i mentioned
earlier looking at the possibilities and
how we can provide additional learning
time for our students to address their
learning gaps
that extension is one of a number of
things ccsd still working on right now
staff are planning in-person graduation
ceremonies
though no details are set yet they're
also looking at ways to safely bring
back spectators for sports